Quand je me réveille le matin, et que je me regarde dans le miroir,
je vois une femme noire.
Pour moi, l'ethnie est visible. Mais toi, tu ne la vois pas. »
Et là, elle a dit quelque chose de vraiment marquant.
Elle a dit : « Les privilèges fonctionnent ainsi.
Les privilèges sont invisibles pour ceux qui les possèdent. »
Je dirais que pour les personnes blanches de cette salle, c'est un luxe
de ne pas avoir à penser à sa couleur chaque seconde de sa vie.
Les privilèges sont invisibles pour ceux qui les possèdent.
Souvenez-vous, j'étais le seul homme de ce groupe,
donc après cette discussion, je me suis exclamé : « Oh non. »
(Rires)
Quelqu'un m'a dit : « C'est quoi cette réaction ? »
J'ai répondu : « Quand je me réveille et me regarde dans le miroir,
je vois un être humain.
Je suis une sorte de personne générique.
Je suis un homme blanc de classe moyenne. Je n'ai ni ethnie, ni classe, ni sexe.
Je suis universellement généralisable. »
(Rires)
Je pense que c'est là que je suis devenu un homme blanc de classe moyenne.
La classe, l'ethnie et le sexe ont cessé d'être le problème d'autres gens,
ils me concernaient.
Il me fallait commencer à penser à ces sujets.
Parce que j'étais privilégié, ils avaient été invisibles pour moi pendant longtemps.
J'aimerais vous dire que cette histoire s'arrête il y a 30 ans
dans ce groupe de discussion.
Mais ça m'a été rappelé récemment à l'université où j'enseigne.
J'ai une collègue, et nous enseignons tous deux la sociologie du genre
en semestres alternés.
Elle est conférencière invitée pendant mon semestre.
Et moi, je le suis pendant son semestre.
Donc, j'entre dans sa classe pour donner ma conférence,
Il y a environ 300 étudiants dans la salle,
et en entrant dans la classe, un étudiant lève la tête et dit :
« Ah, enfin, une opinion objective. »
Durant tout le semestre, dès que ma collègue ouvrait la bouche,
ce que les étudiants voyaient, c'était une femme.
En fait, si vous disiez à mes étudiants :
« Il y a des inégalités structurelles basées sur le sexe aux États-Unis »,
ils diraient : « Bien sûr vous dites ça. Vous êtes une femme, vous êtes partiale. »
Quand je le dis, ils sont : « Wow, c'est intéressant.
Ça sera à l'examen ? Comment on épelle 'structurelle' ? »
(Rires)
J'espère que vous pouvez bien voir,
voici à quoi ressemble l'objectivité.
(Rires et applaudissements)
La rationalité occidentale désincarnée.
(Rires)
D'ailleurs, je pense que c'est pour ça que les hommes portent des cravates.
Parce que si vous voulez incarner la rationalité occidentale désincarnée,
vous avez besoin d'un symbole.
Et quel meilleur symbole de la rationalité occidentale désincarnée qu'un accessoire
qui, d'un côté est un nœud coulant et de l'autre pointe vers les organes génitaux?
(Rires et applaudissements)
C'est la dualité corps-esprit illustrée.
Donc, rendre le sexe visible aux hommes
est la première étape pour les engager à soutenir l'égalité des sexes.
Quand les hommes entendent parler de l'égalité des sexes,
quand ils commencent à penser au sujet,
ils pensent souvent, beaucoup d'hommes pensent
que c'est normal, que c'est juste, que c'est un impératif éthique.
Mais pas tous les hommes.
Certains hommes — certains sont foudroyés par la révélation
et ils disent : « Oh mon Dieu, oui, l'égalité des sexes ! »
Et aussitôt, ils veulent vous expliquer votre propre oppression.
Ils voient le soutien à l'égalité des sexes comme un appel à la cavalerie :
« Merci mesdames d'avoir attiré notre attention là-dessus,
nous allons nous en occuper maintenant. »
C'est un syndrome que j'ai appelé « auto-satisfaction précoce ».
(Rires et applaudissements)
Il y a un autre groupe, toutefois, qui résiste activement à l'égalité des sexes,
qui voit l'égalité des sexes comme quelque chose de préjudiciable aux hommes.
J'ai été invité à une émission télé, face à quatre hommes blancs.
C'est le début du livre que j'ai écrit : « Des hommes blancs en colère ».
Ces quatre hommes blancs en colère
croyaient que, eux, les hommes blancs d'Amérique,
étaient victimes de discrimination inversée dans le travail.
Ils ont raconté leurs histoires :
comment ils étaient qualifiés pour le job, la promotion,
comment ils ne l'ont pas eu et qu'ils étaient en colère.
Je vous raconte ça à cause du titre de cette émission.
C'était une citation d'un des hommes.
Et la citation était :
« Une femme noire m'a volé mon travail. »
Et tous avaient une histoire,
qualifiés pour le job, pour la promotion,
ne l'ont pas eu, très en colère.
Après, c'était à moi de parler.
Et j'ai dit : « Je n'ai qu'une question pour vous.
Et c'est à propos du titre de l'émission.
« Une femme noire m'a volé mon travail. »
En fait, c'est sur un seul mot du titre.
C'est à propos du mot « mon ».
D'où vous est venue l'idée que c'était votre travail ?
Pourquoi le titre n'est-il pas « Une femme noire a obtenu LE travail »,
ou « Une femme noire a obtenu UN travail ».
Parce que sans nous confronter au sentiment de propriété des hommes,
nous ne comprendrons jamais pourquoi tant d'hommes résistent à l'égalité.
(Applaudissements)
Nous les hommes, pensons que ceci est un terrain équitable.
Dès qu'une loi fait un peu pencher la balance :
on pense : « Oh mon Dieu, l'eau monte.
C'est de la discrimination inversée contre nous. »
(Rires)
Laissez-moi être très clair :
les hommes blancs en Europe et aux États-Unis
sont les bénéficiaires du plus important programme de discrimination positive
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Il s'appelle « l'Histoire du monde ».
(Rires et applaudissements)
J'ai énoncé quelques obstacles au support des hommes.
Mais pourquoi doit-on soutenir l'égalité des sexes ?
Bien sûr, c'est bien, c'est bon, c'est juste.
Mais en plus de ça,
l'égalité des sexes est aussi dans notre intérêt à nous, les hommes.
Si vous écoutez ce que les hommes disent vouloir de leur vie,
l'égalité des sexes est un bon moyen pour obtenir la vie qu'on veut vivre.
L'égalité des sexes est bonne pour les pays.
Il se trouve que, selon la plupart des études,
les pays qui ont le plus d'égalité entre les sexes
sont également les pays qui sont les plus heureux.
Et pas seulement parce qu'ils sont tous en Europe.
(Rires)
Même en Europe, les pays qui ont le plus d'égalité entre les sexes
sont aussi ceux qui ont le plus haut niveau de bonheur.
C'est aussi bon pour les entreprises.
Des recherches menées par Catalyst et d'autres ont montré
que plus les entreprises sont égalitaires,
mieux c'est pour les travailleurs.
Leur main d’œuvre est plus heureuse.
La rotation des emplois est inférieure, le taux d'attrition est plus faible.
Elles ont plus de facilité à recruter.
Le taux de rétention et la satisfaction au travail sont plus élevés,
les taux de productivité sont plus hauts.
La question qu'on me pose souvent dans les entreprises est :
« Alors, cette égalité des sexes, ça va être vraiment cher, hein ? »
Et je dis : « Oh non, en fait, ce que vous devez commencer à calculer,
c'est combien l'inégalité des sexes vous coûte déjà.
C'est extrêmement coûteux. »
Donc, c'est bon pour les affaires.
D'autre part, c'est bon pour les hommes.
C'est bon pour le genre de vie que nous voulons vivre,
parce que les jeunes hommes ont déjà énormément changé,
et ils veulent avoir des vies comblées
par des relations profondes avec leurs enfants.
Ils attendent de leurs partenaires, leurs conjointes, leurs épouses,
qu'elles travaillent,
et qu'elles soient tout aussi engagées dans leurs carrières qu'ils le sont.
Pour vous donner une idée de ce changement —
certains d'entre vous s'en souviennent peut-être.
Quand j'étais plus jeune, il y avait une énigme qu'on nous posait.
Certains d'entre vous vont grimacer en l'entendant.
L'énigme commençait ainsi :
un homme et son fils sont en voiture sur l'autoroute.
Il y a un terrible accident,
et le père meurt.
Le fils est conduit aux urgences, et tandis qu'ils l'amènent à l'hôpital,
le médecin urgentiste voit le garçon et dit :
« Oh, je ne peux pas l'opérer, c'est mon fils. »
Comment est-ce possible ?
Nous étions démunis devant cette énigme.
Il nous était impossible de la résoudre.
(Rires)
J'ai décidé de faire une petite expérience avec mon fils de 16 ans.
Il avait invité des amis à la maison
pour regarder un match à la télé.
Donc, j'ai décidé de leur soumettre cette énigme,
juste pour voir, pour évaluer le niveau de changement.
Eh bien, ces garçons de 16 ans,
ils se sont immédiatement tournés vers moi et ont dit : « C'est sa mère. »
Sans problème, juste comme ça.
Sauf mon fils, qui a dit : « Il pourrait avoir deux papas. »
(Rires et applaudissements)
C'est un indice, un indicateur de comment les choses ont changé.
Les jeunes hommes aujourd'hui s'attendent à pouvoir concilier travail et famille.
Ils veulent être des couples à doubles carrières.
Ils veulent être en mesure de concilier travail et famille avec leur partenaire.
Ils veulent être des pères impliqués.
Alors, il s'avère que plus les relations sont égalitaires,
plus les deux partenaires sont heureux.
Les données des psychologues et sociologues sont très claires.
Je pense que nous avons les bons chiffres, les données, pour prouver aux hommes
que l'égalité des sexes n'est pas un jeu avec des perdants mais gagnant-gagnant.
Voici ce que montrent les données.
Quand nous, les hommes, commençons le processus d'équilibrage
entre travail et vie de famille,
nous utilisons souvent deux phrases pour décrire ce que nous faisons.
Nous filons un coup de main, et nous aidons un petit peu.
(Rires)
Je vais proposer quelque chose d'un peu plus radical,
en un seul mot : « partager ».
(Rires)
Voici ce que montrent les données :
quand les tâches ménagères et l'éducation sont partagées,
les enfants réussissent mieux à l'école.
Les enfants ont un taux d'absentéisme plus faible
et de meilleurs taux de réussite.
Ils risquent moins d'être diagnostiqués hyperactifs,
de voir un psychiatre pour enfants,
et d'être mis sous médicaments.
Donc quand les hommes partagent les tâches ménagères et l'éducation des enfants,
leurs enfants sont plus heureux et en meilleure santé,
et c'est ce que veulent les hommes.
Quand les tâches ménagères et l'éducation sont partagées,
les femmes sont plus heureuses.
(Rires)
Leurs femmes sont aussi en meilleure santé.
Elles ont moins de chances de voir un thérapeute,
d'entrer en dépression,
d'être sous traitement,
plus de chances d'aller à la salle de sport,
et on constate de plus hauts niveaux de satisfaction conjugale.
Quand le partage des tâches est équitable, les femmes sont plus heureuses,
et c'est certainement ce que veulent aussi les hommes.
Quand le partage des tâches est équitable,
les hommes sont en meilleure santé.
Ils fument moins, boivent moins, prennent moins souvent des drogues récréatives.
Ils sont moins susceptibles d'aller aux urgences,
mais plus susceptibles d'aller se faire dépister régulièrement.
Ils risquent moins de voir un thérapeute,
d'entrer en dépression,
d'être sous traitement médical.
Quand le partage des tâches est équitable,
les hommes sont plus heureux et en meilleure santé.
Et qui ne voudrait pas ça ?
Et pour finir, quand le partage des tâches est équitable,
les hommes font plus souvent l'amour.
(Rires)
De ces quatre découvertes fascinantes,
laquelle pensez-vous que la revue Men's Health a mis en couverture ?
(Rires)
« Faire le ménage l'excite.
(Mais pas quand c'est elle qui le fait.) »
(Rires)
Je voudrais dire,
pour rappeler aux hommes dans le public,
que ces données ont été recueillies sur une longue période de temps.
Je ne veux pas que les auditeurs se disent :
« D'accord, je pense que je vais faire la vaisselle ce soir. »
Ces données ont été recueillies sur une très longue période de temps.
Mais ça montre quelque chose d'important.
Quand la revue Men's Health a mis ce titre en une,
ils l'ont aussi appelé, vous allez adorer, « Préli-ménage ».
Donc, nous avons vu des choses vraiment importantes,
que l'égalité des sexes
est dans l'intérêt des pays,
des entreprises, des hommes,
de leurs enfants et leurs partenaires,
que l'égalité des sexes n'est pas une arnaque.
Ce n'est pas un gagnant-perdant,
mais un gagnant-gagnant pour chacun d'entre nous.
Et nous savons aussi
que nous ne pourrons pas pleinement donner leur chance aux femmes et filles
sans engager les hommes et les garçons.
Nous le savons.
Ma position est que nous, les hommes, avons besoin des mêmes choses
que ce dont les femmes ont besoin pour vivre les vies qu'elles veulent,
afin de vivre les vies que nous voulons.
En 1915, à la veille d'une des plus grandes manifestations populaires
sur la Cinquième Avenue de New York,
un écrivain new-yorkais a écrit un article dans un magazine.
Le titre de l'article était :
« Le féminisme pour les hommes. »
Et voici la première ligne de cet article :
« Le féminisme permettra aux hommes d'être libres pour la première fois. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)